if we feel like we have free will why
even care about
whether we don't if the sensation is the
same as having free will
[Music]
this is star talk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and for this episode
we're featuring my conversation with
Joseph Gordon-Levitt oh my gosh if you
if you if you were to make a list of
actors that like did really cool
mind-bending movie roles that he is at
the top of that list Joe welcome to
start talk I don't know if the listeners
can see the smile on my face but hearing
that come out of you it's very
flattering sir thank you so I mean uh
generally people are best known as
actors but you're also a director
producer writer and you enter a bunch of
other stuff we're going to get to in a
few minutes okay uh but uh just recently
during recent years you were in the
trial of the Chicago seven I remember
that well my gosh what a that was an
intense film that was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you were
you were a Gotham police detective in
Dark Knight many people think that was
the best Batman movie of them all I mean
it's among mine that definitely and
stolen is hard to beat it's true yeah it
is it totally is and most recently you
are in the Pinocchio animated feature
and tell me who you are I'm Jiminy
Cricket man that's got to be the coolest
role if you have to pick one nobody
wants to be Pinocchio
I'm the conscience of finokia I know I
couldn't that was one of those moments
when when the director Robert zemeck is
who you know he directed like Back to
the Future yes of course I did another
movie with him a few years ago called
the walk and uh when he called me and
and told me about thinking of me to play
Jiminy Cricket I that was one of those
life moments you're like did you jump at
it you jumped at it it must have been
you know whatever mistakes I've made
it's all good if I'm here and he's
offering me this so thank thank the Lord
now now I'm also tickled because I I
didn't even know this would be ever be
something we could declare but you have
portrayed
to
two famous people in movies each of whom
we have had as guests on Star Talk okay
okay so it's probably not uh Robert Tad
Lincoln because okay that would be
Philippe Petit and everyone Snowden yes
totally we had Philippe Petit and talked
all about his famous walk between the
twin towers and uh also Ed Snowden we
had an interview with him in his in his
uh moving bot there's some he's on the
snowbot the snowball there it is yeah he
was totally in my office I get to say he
was in my office right Spirit energy was
there so it's a little freaky to have
you here who played both of those
characters but we'll get we'll get to
that in a minute one other point is you
uh especially for our listeners who are
strong on the geek Spectrum sure me too
to have been in two movies that just
kind of leave your brain a little
scrambled or a lot scrambled Inception
yeah Christopher Nolan again oh by the
we've had Christopher Nolan as a guest
oh yeah that was fun that was totally
fun and of course Looper as a time
travel uh assassin yeah and so so I just
want to lay out that landscape before we
sort of take this one by one and I just
want to thank you for coming on to the
program oh thank you I'm feeling great
about myself right now okay I needed
that Neil thanks okay
um let's start out with with Looper
um it seems to me by the way who tell me
who directed and wrote that that's Ryan
Johnson who who are the for those on the
geek spectrum that you're talking about
made um the most controversial and in my
opinion best yeah I'm gonna say it the
best Star Wars film The Last Jedi
um Ryan Johnson who also made knives out
and Glass Onion that just came out I was
in his first movie called brick and then
his third movie called Looper I got you
so you're in his you're on his list is
what that sounds like I'm actually
technically in all of his movies I did
the ones that I'm not in with the bigger
part I have like tiny cameos so
um in Looper it doesn't seem too so much
concern itself with and it how do I
characterize it so let me just give the
plot line you are an assassin who kills
bad guys who was sent into the past
thereby disappearing from the future and
then you kill them and dispose of their
body so they're basically wiped off the
face of the Earth yeah anyone in the
future would know or concern and then
you confront yourself as someone you're
supposed to kill a brilliantly played by
Bruce Willis and then there's an issue
there about whether you kill your future
self or not and that's all I'll say
about in case anyone hasn't seen it but
my point is you have an encounter with
your future self and this seems to break
some some time travel uh rules I'm
thinking to myself are there
Joe I thought I could pass that through
you but I couldn't
no but I'm actually I'm curious to ask
you
because I'm a fan of time travel movies
so you know like I mentioned Back to the
Future or you know where you want to
talk about Quantum Leap I was in an
episode of Quantum Leap when I was 10
years old the old oh my god
um but time wait a minute wait wait and
weren't you forgive me weren't you in in
Third Rock yeah yeah oh my God I guess
that's right speaking of a cosmic
perspective
from the Sun oh just just remember that
right it's not in my notes here so I I
just remembered that so you've been at
this for a while oh I've been doing this
a long time feeling good about this okay
so so uh I don't know if there's a rule
we'll have to ask some of our time with
that kind of thing be possible I mean is
there any any indication in any serious
science to say that a human could travel
from one place on the time continuum and
end up in a different place intact with
their same human body and brain yeah I
think there's not that itself is not the
problem the the problem comes about with
as I say the grandfather Paradox all
right where you go back and you prevent
your grandfather from meeting your
grandmother or in a Terminator version
of that you kill your grandfather so
that you're never born to be sent back
in time yeah to meet your grandfather
okay so some so there's a paradoxical
Loop problem yes that uh that Stephen
Hawking thinks there was not there is no
solution to it at all that we will
discover a new time travel conjecture
that will prevent backwards time travel
in that way and there are a couple of
scenarios there's another one wait when
you say a conjecture you mean that
there'll be some kind of evidence or
kind of mathematically backed uh
statement that says this is actually
impossible it'll never happen Stephen
Hawking believed that we would one day
derive either mathematically or expand
environmentally that conjecture it's
just so as to prevent the grandfather
Paradox from unfolding right and so but
what was what's what intrigues me in
Looper you met your future self 30 years
Pence yes and it had conversations with
that person and that's just I don't I
don't know if that's allowed that's what
I'm saying yeah and
I don't know what to say yeah I mean I
think it's definitely not allowed and
look at that we did it anyway okay
no but I mean there's there were there
was actually there was a scene there's a
great scene one of my favorite scenes in
the movie where my character and Bruce
Willis's character who like you're
saying are supposed to be the same man
just younger and older version of the
same man they sit down at a diner
together and talk
and there was a version of The Script
where the older man
explains some of the mechanics of the
time travel
probably in a you know in in terms that
Stephen Hawking would deem serious but
at least in terms that
felt necessary to the story in that
draft of the script but later Ryan in
what I think is a wise move decided to
cut all of that out
and there's just a line now where Bruce
Willis kind of gets prickly and angry
and says we're not going to talk about
time travel oh that's okay so all right
so you leave it more to us to try to
think about it I mean it's interesting
you know this gets into sort of the
theory of what is science fiction and
what's the purpose of Science Fiction
and is Looper even a science fiction
story
certainly gets categorized as sci-fi and
I think in in Hollywood entertainment
anything that involves a kind of
quote-unquote future gets categorized as
sci-fi I mean Star Wars gets categorized
as sci-fi there's no science to any of
the kind of magical Fantastical things
that happen in Star Wars it just gets
categorized when I say that when I say
that I get crucified when I say there's
no science in Star Wars so I'm glad
someone a full up actor gets to declare
that as well so yeah but it's a yeah
it's just it's a it's an aesthetic of it
should be called like you know
futuristic fantasy yeah yeah some other
genre I mean some people call it science
fantasy even like they call they call
you know the Lord of the Rings or the
sort of Shannara or you know these kinds
of fantasy these D Magic Gathering books
that I used to read when I was a
teenager they call him science fantasy
but there's certainly no science to Gand
off they're like it's just sort of words
the entertainment this is the world of
entertainment it is why I'm like so
thrilled to talk to you because I like I
live in this world of entertainment
where words don't mean a damn thing
they're just like Words yeah strung
together yeah together in lines right
right and so I mean look I think Looper
is a brilliant story and it has a lot of
very true things to say about about age
about what it means uh to get older
about what it means to reckon with your
past uh the moral decisions that you've
made and whether you think you've been a
good person a bad person whether you
think you've done the right thing or
done the wrong thing and what can be
done to try to rectify that
um I think there's a lot of very true
things to say about that time travel is
a a fun and
um really cinematic device to tell that
story but I don't think it has anything
to do with how time
physically works well I think the the
out that the movie gives itself is the
whole concept of the loop is there's a
point where
they send back you for you to kill your
future self and at that point you have
30 years until you're going to die and
then you're released from this
Assassin's crowd and and that closes it
off right it so that's something it's a
tidy knot placed it's very tidy that's
it's like if you if you leave aside the
science part of the Science Fiction it's
an impeccable work of fiction yes it is
and you're tied off from the timeline
and then then and you get to live 30
years with a bunch of money for having
killed the people you did so of course
that's not exactly how it turns out no
no spoiler alert yeah I won't tell you
what does happen yeah it's a great
ending actually yeah so so we're all uh
I want to say my people are proud of you
for participating in films like that and
just okay at least
rocking the concepts of it but
understanding that it's that it's
nonsense in terms of science that
there's absolutely none there so the
idea that they cut out the pedantic
explanation for how the time works I
actually applaud that I would have
enjoyed it if I seen it but without it I
don't miss it and I'll tell you why yeah
I was watching The Blues Brothers
director's cut
and there's a scene that was did not
make the original release it's where
they Park their car okay this is the car
that just the car does weird magical
things until the very end when it
completely collapses outside of the the
tax assessor's office so that this is
this is like
only for Blues Brothers fans you're
going to care about what I'm about to
say I know the car you're talking about
yeah so yeah it's a car and they park it
near
a nuclear power plant
all right and then they go into their
apartment and so they they thought that
that would allow you to give it some
cause some mechanism for having the
powers that it did but but in the end
when they took it out all he had to say
was we're on a mission from God
you don't need physics you're on a
mission from God so no I just feels more
honest it feels more honest exactly and
you know just let it be let the story be
what it is and if you try to over
explain it uh you can end up derailing
the the magic of what is trying to be
conveyed so I I I'm I'm I embrace the
fact that they removed that scene for
what that's worth I appreciate it as as
an authoritative scientist uh that's a
good seal of approval to have we've got
to take a quick break but when we come
back more of my conversation with Joseph
Gordon-Levitt on Star Talk
we're back continuing my one-on-one
conversation with Joseph Gordon-Levitt
so now on to onto Inception uh oh my
gosh we uh I was I was with it until you
went into the head of the dream of the
person in the head yeah did you go too
deep how many deep did you go at one
point oh man it's been a while since
I've reviewed this but uh it was like
two or three deep yeah I think there are
three layers yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
and each lady they just made something
up each layer time passes at one tenth
the speed of the previous layer yeah so
if you're two layers in it's one one
hundredth yeah okay that was a fun
invented thing that will become part of
Canon now yeah you do it why not let
that be the case sure so there's
something to it right like I mean I've
definitely found this is a far from
scientific but when uh I'm having a
dream I could be asleep on the couch and
in real life only a few minutes goes by
but in my dream it seemed like I just
had a whole adventure oh right right
right right so because your brain just
goes whatever Pace it wants to go right
right and so my hunch is that it's very
plastic and obviously this is anecdotal
so I'd be curious to hear what an expert
has to say and I I I'd imagine that the
expert will say well we don't know
exactly yet you know there's still a lot
to learn about the human brain but
um but my my experience whether with
dreams I also had an experience not to
get too tangential but I I once did
a uh a psychedelic drug called DMT oh
yeah and uh my experience was in
objective
life I know something like five minutes
um but my subjective experience
was completely outside of time and space
and felt like I was experiencing
something like infinite time if you know
or eons or like and and so my hunch is
that the brains
subjective experience of time can be
pretty uh Wonky can be pretty plastic so
I guess an interesting question was does
anyone ever go to sleep in their dreams
and then have a dream
has that ever because that's exactly
kind of what your right story is of
inception yeah but I don't ever remember
I had a dream like that I don't ever
remember going to sleep in my dreams I
don't remember doing that wait I'm
trying to remember because I have I've I
when I was in the middle of doing
Inception I was obviously focused a lot
more on this but I I I remember two
different times in my life where I've
had a lucid dream and yeah I understand
the definition of a lucid dream is you
don't know the difference you know
you're dreaming while you're dreaming Oh
that's oh okay and that almost never
happens to me right there's two
different times where I believe it has
happened one of the times was
um while I was shooting Inception they
say that it's more prone to happen if
you have it on your mind a lot if you're
spending a lot of your waking time
thinking about dreams it makes sense
that it'll be we'll be more likely uh
it'll be more likely to occur to you
while you're dreaming like oh hey maybe
I'm dreaming and I do I remember
something my memory memory is is patchy
of the dream but it had to do with
waking up and a bed like the most Vivid
uh visual memory I have of the dream was
like the bed that I was just sleeping in
and so I had some kind of notion that I
was dreaming and it had to do with
sleeping and I so there was that and
then the other lucid dream I had I
didn't go to sleep in it but I um it
also was very Inception related again
when it's on your mind you're more prone
to think of it it was when Inception was
just coming out so everyone was talking
about it I was talking about it a lot
Etc and I was it was during a nap I was
working on something else I was napping
uh in between shots and I had a dream
that it literally started very similarly
to a scene of that that is in Inception
I was like running down a hallway and
and I realized oh wait I'm Dreaming I
can control this and and I had that
realization and the first thing I
thought was like okay if I'm Dreaming I
can do anything
let's have incredible sex right now and
that that just didn't work and I started
to wake up and I was like okay wait wait
no don't don't wake up don't wake up
don't wake up okay I give up the sex
it's fine and then I remember I was like
maybe I don't I can't control it but I
still just want to see what happens in
this dream and I got to the end of the
hallway and then I was in like a bit it
was it turned really mundane I was in
some kind of big mattress store
and like shopping for mattresses oh what
a waste but there was one weird thing
about it was like there was some kind of
weird we could like float and like do
the kind of like flips and somersaults
you do when you're in a pool we were
just doing that in the air at the
mattress store
but and was like yeah see We're Dreaming
here I am dreaming this is happening wow
crazy okay so I think the lesson here is
Joe you're not supposed to get that much
into the character
what's my motivation that dream I just
had
mattresses
[Laughter]
so um you have to explain something to
me because I just didn't understand it
and I didn't see the movie twice but I
probably should have okay what was the
what was the point of the little dreidel
top thing what was that the meaning of
this yeah I like that you called it a
dreideline talking to a nice Jewish boy
here okay yeah the top the spinning top
well so they call it a totem in the
movie and that everyone kind of has
their own and it's a a device that you
have that you try to use to tell whether
or not you're dreaming and how does why
would the top know this
uh it's I don't think it's so much that
the top knows it's that if if the top
just spins and Spins and Spins and Spins
and never Falls that's that's sort of
you doing that you must be dreaming you
know they're they're like there are
other
there are other
um
more normal or uh I guess traditional
ways that people try to determine that
they're dreaming like one is try to pick
up a book or read something if if you're
in a dream and you're wondering Am I
Dreaming if you can manage to pick up a
book and look at the pages
uh it'll it'll indicate whether you're
dreaming or not because it's very
difficult for a dreaming brain to
actually produce
potentially in a book so the the book
will be just kind of gibberish and
that's a sign that you're dreaming
another one is like just to look at a a
clock or a watch it usually it's it's
mumbo-jumbo if you're dreaming
um it's interesting so you're trying to
create tangible realities that reality
does trivially and your brain would have
to work hard at it yeah and for and and
so in Inception everybody has a certain
personal device that they use to try to
trust if you're losing track of wait Am
I Dreaming or is this reality you have
your totem that you've kind of trained
yourself to know I spin this top and if
it falls I know I'm in reality and if it
doesn't fall I know I'm Dreaming okay so
that's why there's the spinning topic
they were testing the laws of physics
that okay yeah that's basically dream
physics would be different from real
physics that's what it comes down to
that's right yes because in dream
physics your mind is the one that's
making it happen not the actual laws of
right exactly exactly all right so one
one other movie just I want to bring to
the front here you are the voice of
Jiminy Cricket oh my yes sir that's got
to be the dream role of them all so now
I got a level with you I read the
original Pinocchio the original the
original by cloudy from like 100 years
ago or something correct correct and
Italian right what
I've read an English translation okay
all right okay I was gonna be impressed
but yeah yeah yeah so I don't know how
many people know that Jiminy Cricket
like dies in the second chapter of the
book yeah the cricket yeah in in the
original he's not and he's not Jiminy
Cricket I don't think he's just like
this and and he is he is Pinocchio's
conscience because Pinocchio is this bad
boy and he doesn't do anything right
doesn't listen to any adult advice and
Jiminy Cricket is trying to guide him
along and what I read There was in the
in the story Pinocchio gets so angry
with him he throws his shoe to the
Crickets on the wall throws a shoe at it
and smears the cricket on the wall end
of Jiminy Cricket and the whole rest of
the story continues so Disney is so
lying to us with that original movie now
forgive me I have yet to see your
current project with yeah with Pinocchio
so how close to the original story is it
there are no boots thrown no it's it's
an adaptation of the Disney version of
Pinocchio not the original I mean but
it's true like this is something I like
to think about a lot is what what's
really original you know because
Cinderella that's also not originated
with Disney or Aladdin or you know
Beauty and the Beast these all go back
and uh and Shakespeare didn't write the
first version of Romeo and Juliet oh I
didn't know that and Judy Garland wasn't
in the original version of The Wizard of
Oz it's there were there were earlier
versions you know and so I don't know I
to me
originality is almost a myth like
everything that any artist creates is
something else drawing so heavily on so
many influences that uh and and to me
there's nothing wrong with that that
doesn't make it any less valuable and to
me what I look for more is
it is the artist uh saying something
honest are they doing it in a heartfelt
way are they saying something uh you
know clever or funny or whatever these
these things original is just it's
really hard to say what exactly is
original so if I may Echo that in the
world of science they're making
technology there are many things though
this is the first this done by this
person burning the midnight oil
overnight and it's Eureka and it's it's
like never that it's like hardly ever
that and I think we want that to be true
and so we force narratives to match it
but uh yeah there's always something
that came before the something else and
I don't think we give enough credit for
that yeah that's that's really I agree
with you entirely well it makes a better
story if there's a singular Hero at the
center of the story that you can
valorize right okay in fact any given
great invention or any given movie
that's you know we we talk about like
we're talking about Christopher Nolan an
Inception obviously he was amazing but
he'll be the first to say he had a whole
great enormous team of people that all
helped to make that movie and those
collaborators get you know by the way
when we interviewed him he spent 10
minutes talking about 2001 A Space
Odyssey yeah and how influential that
was on him when he was a kid exactly so
so yeah that's very I I like you say
it's honest and our urge to valorize
makes maybe a better story but it's not
the better truth right so this is a
fascinating reality I I really uh I
admire the scientific Community for
um at least in principle and I'm sure
this doesn't always happen in practice
being less about the the ego of look at
me look at me and more about hey we're
trying to drive at the truth it might
take lots of us you know someone's going
to conduct a study and their findings
are gonna you know not necessarily be
the bullseye but the fact that they
covered that ground then helps the next
person find the bullseye maybe a
generation later or whatever that I I
just think that it's really admirable
that kind of team playership and not
enough people even know to think that
way so I'm glad to it counts you among
those who who appreciate that moving
Frontier of science we got to take our
second and final break but when we
return more of my conversation with
Joseph Gordon-Levitt
we now return to my one-on-one
conversation with actor producer
director Joseph Gordon-Levitt so dude
you've done other things what tell me
about what is hit record media what is
that
so hit record is an online community
that I started with my brother many many
years ago
it started as just uh
because I well I've been acting ever
since I was six years old when I was 19
I quit acting and go to college and uh
when I wanted to get back into it I
couldn't get a part no one would cast me
in any roles and that was painful I
would have kept if I had any power I
would have cast you just knowing you
were in Third Rock From the Sun that
would have been sufficient well that
that's part of it is I so I mean I loved
being on Third Rock From the Sun but I
also like what I wanted to do was you
know a movie that would play at Sundance
I wanted to do something different than
what I'd been doing you know and the
thing is Hollywood isn't great I mean
look the human race isn't great at
thinking outside the box and thinking
people can do something different than
what they've done before
and and so it was very difficult to
convince anybody to cast me in a movie
that would play at Sundance Ryan Johnson
who we've talked about was one of the
first ones to do it in his movie Brick
uh went to Sundance but um but the pain
and kind of humiliation of wanting so
badly to make my art to express myself
to do my thing and not getting to do it
sent me into this uh sort of
introspective Journey
and I came out thinking okay
I can't wait around for someone else to
cast me I've got to take responsibility
for my own creativity
and that's when I came up with this
little turn of phrase which at the time
was just my own kind of
self-motivational Mantra to hit record
like I'm gonna be the one to push the
button and you know like pushing that
record button on a on a camcorder or on
a you know on any kind of recording
device and it was of course a bit of
word play too with hit record and hit
record because the the word play with
hit record is you know the media was and
continues to change and uh a hit record
is sort of something from the old media
back when media was
an object that people would buy and I
saw then and some of this has come to
pass
and some of it hasn't
um I saw then like the media is going to
change instead of being objects that
people buy it's going to be more of an
activity that people do and so changing
hit record
to hit record like you be the one you'd
be the one to push a button and uh and
so that's that's how it started this is
brilliant I I can't tell you and I'm not
even in your world except for some very
brief cameos
um I don't want to brag but I have a
cameo in Sharknado six okay I think I
think Academy overlooked my performance
that year that was quite a flex you know
people in the can you tell that
so so I think about this all the time
Joe that you can have you can be a
talented actor but you're passively
waiting around for some opportunity that
could be the opportunity of a lifetime
or it could go to somebody else and so
you're not in control of the access the
public has to your talent and so that
explained to me why so many actors are
also becoming producers and directors
and and I add more power to them it
shouldn't just be a one Guild uh
Universe yeah that's usually when
whenever anybody asks me hey I want to
be an actor I I love it I want to do it
what's your advice sort of my first
piece of advice is don't just act don't
wait around for someone to cast you and
say like oh I'm only an actor like learn
how to write learn how to shoot learn
how to edit make friends make things
make stuff yourself don't don't just
wait around there it is that's that's it
that's entirely it and that that's what
hit record was so I just started making
a bunch of my my own little things
videos and songs and stories and stuff
and I put them on a website that my
brother helped me set up called hit
record and uh and your brother is your
brother my brother Dan yeah Dan okay
yeah who who sadly is is uh died 12
years ago oh my gosh oh yeah so so hit
record continues for me to be a way that
I I get to feel connected with him too
okay very good and there's still a lot
of his
um dare I say spirit in the record
Community because what what happened was
this community by the way you could also
say there's some of his DNA in the yeah
well there's definitely there's some of
his code there's like the spiritual side
and the scientific side right yeah so
you can say his Spirit energy or his DNA
yeah both of us mean exactly the same
thing yeah to The Listener oh that's
interesting do you think spirit and DNA
mean exactly the same thing in the way
you were using it I think it does but
does what is there really his DNA in in
hit record well no I guess I share some
of his DNA
literally man yes
really correct yeah but but you have
this interest in education as well yeah
we have met
in this way because you got involved
with master class that's exactly right I
did a master class that's that's some
high profile teaching I was doing there
because yeah with the budget they put at
the production values and and the talent
that they acquire for it and and how
they package it it's a real professional
outfit and then I learned that you're
engaged with them tell me how that
happened what what's your role yeah so
the mission of hit record was I'll kind
of Connect the Dots here it was always
you know it it started as a way for me
to find my own creativity it evolved
into this community where lots of people
were helping each other find their
creativity and that's what we were
always sort of trying to stimulate and
we would do these various collaborative
projects and be like hey we're gonna
make a show or we're gonna make a book
or we're gonna make a record and we can
all do it together and we made all kinds
of things that way
um and uh and then a couple years ago we
realized hey if if our goal is to try to
help people find their creative selves
maybe the most direct way to accomplish
the goal is teach let's teach the
creative skills that people need and so
we started working on that and using our
platform to teach and we launched uh
like a learning thing called class
projects last year and meanwhile I was
friends with David Rogers the CEO of
masterclass
and he saw what we were doing and he was
like wow this is really great what
you're doing maybe we could join forces
and uh and so that's that's what we've
done and so now A bunch of us uh you
know the hit record team we we work
under master class and uh and we're sort
of bringing our experience in in
community and online interactivity and
creativity and content creation uh to
master class and doing some fun stuff
thereby magnifying the entire Enterprise
which is which is a brilliant uh concept
well they I mean and it goes back to my
brother because the thing that he always
talked about on hit record was
you don't have to consider yourself the
type of person who makes art in order to
make art like he was a shy guy growing
up he was a software engineer he never
considered himself the type of guy to
make art and he made a conscious
decision at some point in his life said
I don't want to be like that I could I
could make art and he got into
photography and he got into fire
spinning and he became this like really
extroverted swashbuckling adventurous
guy and uh and so on hit record what he
would always do before he died and this
is the early days of the community was
he was always looking for people not
like the the accomplished artists
but the people who weren't yet
accomplished artists the people who
wanted to do it but didn't feel like
they could who he identified with
because he had that moment of being like
dude this was the life goal of any good
teacher oh my gosh you're describing you
know I I can't tell you how I don't want
to say I'm annoyed by it but I'm not
Enchanted and I get a phone call from a
parent said oh could you meet my kid
their Straight A's in school I'm saying
I don't need bring the person who's
about to fail or the person is
struggling who needs some encouragement
that's who I want to see not the person
who's already floating uh through
through everything so the people who are
not yet discovered uh that's who I I
value as my contribution to what I can
put out there sounds like exactly what
you're doing but you also write produce
and star in a movie where you play a
school teacher that's right yes yes in
the show Mr Corman who is Mr Corman well
Mr Corman was a show that I made
um where I was sort of imagining thing
um
I was sort of imagining my life if
certain things had gone differently uh
just it came from honestly arriving at
kind of a place of adulthood where I I'm
a dad now and I've found my life partner
and I love her so much and I'm so
grateful for so many things of getting
to have my my family and my work and
things like that and and thinking man
so much of that could have gone
differently and it wouldn't have even
been my fault like just luck could have
gone differently and
um and Mr Corman was
sort of an expansion of that thought
experiment of what if I hadn't been
lucky to the point of finding my life
partner or what if I hadn't you know
what if I was
my my work as an artist hadn't yielded a
professional career it could just easily
have not I mean I really think
making money as an artist earning a
living that way a lot of it comes down
to luck and you know have I worked hard
sure but a lot of people work hard and
they don't end up you know earning their
living as an artist it's it's a it's a
crap shoot and and so I I just came up
with uh started coming with this
character of like okay what would I do
then if if luck hadn't gone
towards me making a living as an actor
and an Entertainer what would I have
done one of the things I admire the most
in the world is uh is teaching and
teachers I've had I've had a lot of
teachers in my life who've made such an
impact on me and I I feel like teachers
are just super undervalued I if I if I
could wave a magic wand and try to make
the world a better place one of the
things I would do would be like cool
teachers all make quarter million
dollars basement yearly and and it goes
up from there and what if that was what
we rewarded in our society instead of
rewarding you know Investment Banking
and you know speculative blah blah blah
why couldn't we do that and uh so I I
wanted to do something about that and I
ended up writing a show about a teacher
okay where can we find that because I I
I've not heard of it until I dug it up
oh yeah it's on it's on Apple TV plus
Apple TV plus okay excellent well thanks
for thanks for that tip yeah so any on
particular School influences you had if
you were an actor as early as age six
yeah did you were you in a special
school for actors or were you like a
regular kid who just stepped out to you
know to do your thing I I was some of
both so and this is a big credit uh to
my parents because it it is more
convenient and and it's it's easier
for a working kid to just uh work and do
kind of homeschool but
you can go to a normal school and then
work but it just takes the the
logistical coordination of making sure
that your your teacher at work is in
communication with your teacher at
school and you get all your homework and
all your tests and all of that and so my
my mom you know God bless her would
would did all that for me and I'm so
grateful that she did that I did get to
go to a normal school throughout and uh
and made some of my best friends was
your art teacher an acting teacher
better than your science teacher
that's funny are you one that got away
from us
I was wondering I have to put it out
there no obligation it's a good question
I I remember I remember one good science
teacher I remember her name was um Miss
antossian she taught biology in like
10th grade but even I mean I I felt like
her hands are a little tied because
you have to learn in this way where
you're just looking at a textbook and
you're memorizing the Bold terms and it
does these terms yeah it doesn't feel
like I I think it wasn't until later in
life kind of through my own curiosity
that I came to understand what science
really is and uh by the way largely
through you know efforts of you and and
other communicators like you who take it
upon themselves to try to step outside
of the scientific community and not just
speak insularly but share the the
process and the knowledge with the wider
world if not for communicators like you
I think I would understand science a lot
less so I'm grateful to you for that
what I'd like to what I would Infuse in
what you just said is whether or not I
actually taught you anything
Mike a bigger goal than that for me is
reigniting
flames of curiosity that we all had as
young children and somehow it gets sort
of worn out of us so beaten out of us
through Middle School yeah so for you to
say when you were older only then did
you then you know this curiosity was
still with you and you would then
explore the science that when curiosity
is a part of who and what you are you
become uh a self-learner right because
you can't go to class anymore right
you're you're an adult you're married
you have kids whatever yeah so I'm
delighted to hear that you retained a
level of curiosity whatever role I
played in that I'm delighted to know
that well thank you thank you and that
that circles back to master class that's
that's what master class is all about
it's like kind of trying to help people
be lifelong Learners your master class
is awesome and you listen to Star Talk I
would really recommend you know check
out the the Neil deGrasse Tyson
masterclass for sure this is a man who's
VP of their of their artists well you
know I'm not saying it's an unbiased
perspective but you know
so Joe I do this with all my guests uh
excuse me all my celebrity guests and I
want to ask you is there any question
you have Harvard about the universe that
you've just never got answered and now
we are you are face to face with an
astrophysicist here's your chance I'm
just saying oh yeah about anything it
could be like God or aliens or the Big
Bang or Pluto wherever whatever is your
fancy yeah okay I I want to ask about I
mean I think astrophysics plays into
this in a way
but it's one of those big questions I
like to I like to get everyone's
perspective on this one is and it's an
it's an old question the whole Free Will
question do we really have any actual
agency or is it already all determined
and I don't know my my understanding
when I talk to many folks who are
who lean into science is hey it's all a
chain reaction you know equal and
opposite reaction Etc it's all physics
one thing leads to another leads to
another leads to another and so all the
way back to the Big Bang it's all
predetermined and any sort of feeling
you have that you're controlling your
life or making decisions is Just an
Illusion and of course that's a sort of
confusing or frustrating Prospect is
that what you believe knowing what you
know about how the universe works I'm
not authorized to comment further
so I can tell you this all the
neuroscientists I speak with
will tell you that you have no free will
in the sense that your brain has already
decided what you will do next before you
have any conscious awareness of it yeah
yeah so it's your conscious awareness
that makes you think you are deciding
but in fact the neurochemistry of your
brain is taking in all the information
and making the next decision for you so
I have no reason to doubt what they're
saying but what I would say is if it if
we feel like we have free will why even
care about
whether we don't if the sensation is the
same as having free will now something
that might get us out of that dilemma is
quantum physics right because quantum
physics is not deterministic
this whole thing where there's a chain
of events would cause and effect that
goes back to the big bang that goes out
the window with quantum physics the the
double slit for example right yeah the
the construct of reality is altered by
interaction with the reality as well as
the fact that the world unfold at that
level probabilistically not
deterministically so there's only a
chance you're going to appear over here
instead of over there and it's been
suggested that our very origin of
Consciousness the very concept of a new
thought is this probabilistic triggering
of your neurochemistry that is a is a is
a Wonderland of of thoughts that have no
precursors at all and so that's what I
think is true and I'm sticking with it I
like that that I I read once uh Richard
Feynman said
um if you think you understand
quantum physics then you don't
understand it or something yeah correct
that's exactly right it's not there to
understand it's just there to be and by
the way this decade is the Centennial
anniversary of the discovery of many of
the tenets of quantum physics oh really
so I'm going to try to try to get that
out
um into the public a little more just so
they can appreciate because there is no
creation storage or retrieval of
information in the modern I.T world
without exploiting the quantum so the
quantum is with us to stay and it took
decades to to to commercialize it to
turn it into a something that
Civilization knows about and cares about
but
um nonetheless that could be our out in
that could be our Escape clause for what
we think of as free will Free Will is
what goes on when quantum physics is
deciding what next to happen through no
cause at all but it's not me deciding
still
I want it to be me oh I want to do it
okay you keep thinking that they keep
thinking that I won't I won't stop you
well Joe it's been a delight having you
on
um I'm gonna show up on on a on a
podcast you're doing with the master
class folk I'd look forward yes yeah and
what what a repository of folks you're
going to draw from there oh my gosh yeah
and you're gonna be the first one all
right all right I'm really really
excited I think try to set the bar in
the right place good good and if you on
any other new projects that have some
fun science in it just give us a holler
okay delighted to put you on and talk
about it and and like I said we have uh
we we live in the geekiverse and that's
a whole as we've come to learn with
Comic-Con and other sort of places of
organized geekdom that this is an
important Force operating within our
culture the fact that you know hundreds
of thousands of people care about this
sort of thing in the same way yeah it's
it's a beautiful thing yeah and uh great
to have you part of that thank you so
much I'm glad to be a part of it I'm
really glad to meet you all right you've
been listening to my exclusive
conversation with actor writer producer
Joseph Gordon-Levitt hope you enjoyed it
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]